[Music]
it's art man oh man I hope they do
something with this [ __ ] or something
I like it when people do crime and go
hey but it's art though no I was just
thinking about that Netflix fooling with
the [ __ ] Jake Gyllenhaal where they
[ __ ] kill people and then they lay
yeah submitted by I have tiger fever
people are people I say that baby fever
and I see his pictures there's never a
moment when I see him science I'll post
more of him being yeah cuz I'm having
tantrums and then I was gonna be like no
no no no I'm not ready why don't we look
him in the eye he always runs a clown I
think I think he does have his little
baby tantrums and he's so strong he
throws his own stroller
he got scared he's pretty strong though
when I chased him for holding my keys he
was like terrified like I was about to
kill him when yeah it was a while ago ah
it was pretty funny though he stated ban
caused chaos during a concert in a
college cafeteria why do they start
playing music if people started cramping
as they were eating their food do people
still call rump these days yes the deuce
really oh yeah it's all still all over
the world so it was like specifically in
one area now right he's one of the
inventors he cloudy he's in the krump
documentary so he must some have some
kind of association to that world if
he's Tommy the clown then he's not
clumping then there's two different
things
well anyway well what happened is he
went to my friend's birthday party
anyway moving on she just wanted a brat
I have a couple of [ __ ] things to say
about that dope I forgot my braids did
mr. tenure he says it still exists oh
yeah you see it all over Europe Asia
Korea all over the place now it's also
embedded in a lot of the choreography -
yeah it's like a little piece you could
just see where they're inspired by it
with that face Dave that's what it looks
like
anytime you see one like this they pull
it back and we go that's part of it oh
yeah even if they're going like this
that's pumping in whatever the wave that
they're doing that's like I was gonna
suck a dick but I realize I'm not gay
alright so this happened at Berklee
College of Music in Boston I wanted to
go to that school I decided not to go I
didn't even apply and I saw the price
tag and I crushed my old dreams what
were you gonna play I know what were you
gonna play I was gonna do sound
engineering thank God cause that [ __ ] is
boring
Oh boring but I know a lot about it but
it's all boring man so there was this
video performance that took place in the
cafeteria where this band called
in that's buddy once you're [ __ ] in
cells
what can you loser with no ball sacks so
an cells are people that are
involuntarily celibate like there they
want it's mainly white heterosexual men
just can't get any [ __ ] exactly [ __ ]
haters they hate you know oh thank you
remember that Santa Barbara dude that's
not a [ __ ] it felt is even in some
Messiah everyone looks up to him he
might be in self [ __ ] god damn yes
listen even his band's new punk rock
student band I think good I feel like it
might be good cuz they go to Berkeley
yeah I don't know what they sound like
and they're talking about this video but
I don't have this video I love how
they're proud about it yeah it might be
a troll band you know their performance
here this woman appears on stage and a
white t-shirt a bra and underwear and
the the band starts playing behind her
and then someone in the band begins
pouring a bucket of pig's blood on her
he curses into the microphone and then
she's just like dancing in the blood
that's all part of the Act
the band finishes a set so that's the
whole thing right and then I got
uploaded to Facebook but then I was
taken down soon after why that
performance received a lot of backlash
from Berkeley students and
administrators their off-key the
performance was just like yeah the music
really sucked I'm sorry man well it was
like the pig's blood - made a lot of
people in comfortable and it also a
grocery blog because took place in the
cafeteria so they're like sanitary like
why couldn't you do this in the [ __ ]
locker room yeah but then they were like
oh we think we cleaned up the pig blood
oh it's art yeah so they're saying that
they did not approve like the calf shows
team did not approve and does not
condone that band's behavior or the
inappropriate themes portrayed in the
show you know what blows my mind is
young people always was supposed to be
the ones that are like pushing the
boundaries and changing the world with
like controversy and and expressing
through art now they're like the social
conduct police which is what's always a
role of old people
yeah so I'm just Mike mind blown like
why the [ __ ] are these hall monitors
everywhere now yeah I think because it's
the cool thing to do it being a hall
monitor is cool now social currency
we're living in such a PC so it is
mind-blowing
yeah because before it's like the young
young kids were the ones that were
pushing the boundaries with new thought
right it's like like the haircut version
of that would be like getting a mohawk
like I'm gonna go anti-society this is
some crazy like edgy [ __ ] but now it's
like the young people just having like a
no [ __ ] getting haircut and then like
like they look old like mr. Rogers or
something and then they're like why
can't everyone be like me it's so weird
it's a gap that's opposite or it is the
guy with the Mohawk that's super super
controlling and he's like sjw and stuff
yeah
except my septum piercing so the band
they did say that it was meant to be
satirical and entertainment I saw it
from a mile away that I was like that so
I was like a troll band yeah even the
band name and cell Messiah it pokes fun
at the insult culture right and that
expression is basically I don't even
have to see the performance I could
pretty self-explanatory right it's how
they're [ __ ] on women because they
can't get laid
yeah why can't they see that or people
that [ __ ] dance especially a school
coming from Berkeley it's art school
like art students can't even see that
yeah the students are calling a
misogynistic and offensive oh why are
they so literal does everyone have
Asperger's now exactly because it's
probably [ __ ] art school and by the
way for a [ __ ] art school this is
pretty like it's my own it's very mild
it just blows my [ __ ] mind dude not
to mention musics supposed to be about
expression anarchy did yes it's about
sometimes counterculture you know and
the fact that they're taking it so
literally it's kind of weird you know
one of those students this is one of the
quotes so it says people are ridiculing
them the band just refusing to even
attempt to come to a compromise
conclusion this indirectly discourages
people to take a risk with their art
because they're being so mercilessly
criticized by their peers it's
ridiculous and paints a really negative
environment for the Berkeley community
there's one student agrees with you guys
yeah cuz I think it's one thing to have
an opinion about it right and to be like
I don't like that you know [ __ ] with
completely another thing to like
suppress that and be like no you cannot
express in that way and you cannot say
that I mean because that defeats the
whole point of what art is then I also
think why people go by a different set
of rules like a lot of these guys like
louis c.k or like maybe this band or
whatever like being white guys they
probably get more flack from other white
people where they're not gonna turn
around and say that to a minority doing
anything that you know like for so for
example there's a lot of controversial
behaviors coming out from
black hip-hop artists or whatever but
you don't see white kids trying to put
them under control or do your musics
miss misogynistic or whatever like you
know you might see that within their own
community but you don't see it from
other white kids yeah so I think they
are held to a different standard
standard or whatever because like we do
have immunity to a lot of things because
we're not white we could say a lot of
[ __ ] just like on this show we could say
whatever the [ __ ] we want
oh yeah like how feel while was saying
when he came in he thought we were
fearless but that's because we don't
have the same consequences that field
got yellow privilege we got yellow
privilege that's what I'm saying we're
like that [ __ ] borderline like group
that like no one really gives a [ __ ]
about us so we could say whatever [ __ ]
we want but at the same time they don't
even know any Asians so they don't know
what to say back or do so it's like no
[ __ ] about trying to make is mainstream
fault yeah so they're saying the band
said that they don't condone and sell
behavior at all or the infant offensive
language that they used in the skit that
they're all feminists they just wanted
to put a spotlight on toxic culture
that's the funny part is like they're
fighting for the team that's that's so
[ __ ] stupid even post it up on
Facebook and invitation to anyone I
wanted to discuss about or like voice
their concerns about their performance
to go to one of the members apartment
but I bet you they don't even want to
talk no one reached out but then there
were other students saying like well you
know we don't want to go to their
apartment after that performance I carry
you like be head blood everywhere this
is a phenomenon that is happening within
very like extreme left groups though
like in college campuses and whatever
like there's people that come out and
they're against stuff but they don't
want to have a conversation or they
don't know how to have debate over a
concept that they don't agree with I
mean it's kind of like the pool
correctness of our society we're at now
it's gotten so extreme people are
sensitive about everything you know
and it's like just because we use a
certain word doesn't mean we're
attacking like a certain group of people
or whatever it's just meant to be more
lighthearted but then like now
everybody's so sensitive about oh you
can't say that I say well [ __ ] out [ __ ]
[ __ ] pretty much except for [ __ ]
except for [ __ ] except for what do you
call it like [ __ ] [ __ ] well I do say
[ __ ]
except for [ __ ] except for not a
little person okay except for watching
what's that other word that I say Travel
training Oh [ __ ] you don't say it I
don't say that anymore I don't say fat
well I already said fact I don't say
that anymore I say I don't say I don't
say okay I do but in a good way
I like God I was just watching your
fingers I like how you said like this
and then it came back to keep going it
just get recipie but but the times
change right like the words that we used
to say
yeah but then now I just say I still say
like things that are controversial yeah
I mean I don't know man I just feel like
people got too sensitive you know and
it's like that kind of is like a
self-fulfilling prophecy of like okay if
we're looking at things with that type
of mindset and that type of behavior
obviously we're just gonna get more and
more uptight and then that kind of
suppresses you know certain things like
like this is an instance right these
guys are just musical artists and
obviously they're being a troll ban
right they're being satirical they are
making fun of that but the fact that you
have to sit there and explain to people
like this is what we actually meant and
then now we need to also have a social
discussion of like okay art students
yeah
by the way like we'll have an open
conversation open diet yeah that's funny
because that's like a math student not
understanding math this is there's all
you know these are art music students
and they don't understand it and for all
of us we see that a mile of [ __ ] way
and I'm like they shouldn't even get
their bachelor's
what the [ __ ] go back to kindergarten
[ __ ]
[Music]